THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY WILL
COME TO ORDER ANY RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN. THANK TO
PROTECT ALL OF US WE ARE
LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN IN HEARING TO THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES- TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO
THIS HEARING ROOM AND ALSO TO.
THE NUMBER BELOW HEARING ROOM-
BUT WE ALSO ARE ALLOWING OUR
OUR REMOTE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
BY TELECONFERENCE AND FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO- GIVE
US PUBLIC COMMENT IN THAT WAY.
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
BUT LET ME GIVE IT TO YOU NOW
IT IS. 877-226-8152 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN- WHEN WE
MOVED. TO A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND YOU
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
THEN YOU WAIT FOR THE OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER AND
WHEN THEN. WHEN THEY CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER THEN YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE ASK OF COURSE THAT YOU
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
EITHER WATCHING THE HEARING ON
OR LISTENING TO IT ON. SO THAT.
WE DON'T GET THAT DOUBLE NOISE
WHILE YOU'RE TRYING TO GIVE US
YOUR TESTIMONY. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE HEARING ALL THE
BILLS ON OUR SCHEDULE AFTER THE
INITIAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WE WILL LIMIT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM. AS CUSTOMARY
IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE CAN BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
AND OF ASK FOR YOUR PATIENCE
BECAUSE- TECHNOLOGY CAN CAUSE
GLITCHES SO THERE MAY BE LACK
TIMES BUT MOST THE TIME IT
WORKS- WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. S. B. TWO FIFTY
THREE PATTERSON IS BEING PUT
OVER BY THE COMMITTEE AND WILL
BE HEARD NEXT WEEK. AND THERE
ARE FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT AND
THE BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT
OR AB TWO SIX THREE AB SEVEN
ONE EIGHT AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. AND I AM CHEERING TODAY
BECAUSE OUR FUTURE SENATOR
BRADFORD- HAVE NEEDS TO BE
ELSEWHERE. OUR BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON OUR BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- ARE.
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD
A CHOKE WELCOME TROUBLED HERE
COM MARKER HERE COME LONGER
HERE SKINNER HERE IN OUR HERE
WINNER. WIENER PRESENTS
MCCORMICK OUR CANCEL MISS
KENNEDY NOTES THAT A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED SO CAN I HAVE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. EXCELLENT SO MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. CONSENT
CALENDAR BRADFORD A CHOI BOGUE.
JO'BURG I CALM WATER FROM UNDER
AYE SKINNER ALL RIGHT IN OUR
AYE WINNER. WHEN OUR EYES
CONSENT CALENDARS FOR VOTES.
EXCELLENT CONSENT CALENDARS
FAST THAT'S FOUR ZERO AND WE
WILL THEN MOVE TO OUR FIRST
BILL WHICH IS AB FIVE ONE FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. AND YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR ALLOWING ME 2% AB FIVE ONE
FIVE AB FIVE ONE FIVE CLARIFIES
TRUST PASSING PROVISIONS
EXCLUDE REPOSSESSION AGENCIES
TO PROTECT ITS EMPLOYEES WHILE
SEARCHING FOR COLLATERAL
HOWEVER REPOSSESSED REHEARSAL
CENTER TO TRESPASSING LAWS A
PRIVATE AND SECURE LOCATION.
DAHLE PROVIDES UNDER THE RUBRIC
REPOSSESSION ORDER A
REPOSSESSION AGENCY OR ITS
EMPLOYEE MAY COME TO THE
PROPERTY TO RECLAIM THE
PURCHASE THAT IT'S FALLEN INTO
DEFAULT. BY THE MISS OF THIS
PROCESS DEBTORS WILL OFTEN CALL
THE POLICE CLAIMED EVERY
POSSESSOR IS TRESPASSING ONTO
THEIR PROPERTY AS A RESULT THE
RE POSSESSORS GETS RUN ITS
THREE ARRESTED REQUIRED TO GO
TO COURT FOR TRESPASSING. ON
FOR THE CASES GET DISMISSED AT
THE HEARING DUE TO BE PROCESSES
ARRESTS THEY NOW COME WITH THE
REST HISTORY FOR SIMPLY DOING
THEIR JOB AB FIVE ONE FIVE
WOULD CLARIFY THE RESISTORS ARE
NOT PUNISH MORE ARRESTED FOR
TRESPASSING WHILE SEARCHING.
FOR THE CLIENT I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON SB FIVE ONE FIVE TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE SIMPLY
DOING THEIR JOB. ON THE LINE
MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A GVA RISEN
JOE COLLINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. A
LICENSE RESISTORS. OUR WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR- LEADS FOR. MR
AYERS. MEMBERS MY NAME IS G. B.
AIRS MY REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE RECORDS
ASTERS THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE
CALOR IS SPONSORING AB FIVE
FIFTEEN TO CLARIFY THE
REPOSSESS YOUR IS NOT
TRESPASSING WHEN THEY ARE
REPOSSESSION COLLATERAL ON-
UNLOCK AND OPEN PRIVATE
PROPERTY. THE BILL- TAKES LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUT OF THE MIDDLE
BETWEEN. THE PROPERTY. OWNER
THE REPOSSESSION- AND- A LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT HAVE TO
THIS BETWEEN OR WHETHER OR NOT.
TRESPASSING OCCURRING HERE. AND
THE BILL DOES NOT ALLOW THE
REPOSSESS YOUR TO ENTER A HOUSE
A GARAGE AN OUTBUILDING OR OR
LOCKED GATES- THOSE ARE OUR
LICENSING ACT IN THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS CODE PROHIBITS. US
FROM DOING THIS SO THE BILL
DOES NOT. CHANGE THAT AT ALL
THE BILL DOES NOT ALLOW-
REPOSSESSION TO CUT LOCKS
REPORTS INTRIGUED THAT'S
PROHIBITED- BY THE PENAL CODE-
AND SO- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
HAS BEEN SAFEGUARDS THAT NEED
TO BE IN PLACE THERE. I HAVE
WITH ME JOE COLLINS CALORIES
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON TO TESTIFY
ON THE BILL AND TO ADDRESS ANY.
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO COLLINS. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS JOE COLLINS
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LESSONS WITH
INVESTORS AND WE'VE BEEN
SHARING A LARGE CHURCH AND
REPOSSESSIONS BEING ARRESTED
AND IN ORDER FOR A CONSUMER TO
GET THEIR CAR BACK ONCE IT'S
BEEN JOSH. AND IT'S GOTTEN SO
FAR IS RECENT REPOSSESSIONS
ARRESTED FOR JUST DRIVING A
MALL PARKING LOT. FOR
TRESPASSING SO THIS IS BILL
DOES GIVE US ANYTHING EXCEPT
FOR THE FACT THAT. A GENEROUS
FOR TRESPASSING. THE COLORATURA
ALREADY HAS A PROVISION THAT
SAYS WE CAN'T ENTER A PLACE
THAT'S NOT AND SECURE. THAT IS
NEVER THE QUESTION THE QUESTION
IS IF WE PICK UP THE CAR IN A
PARKING LOT- WE CAN FIND
OURSELVES BEING A- FOR A
TRESPASS AND IT'S OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. AND WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO PUT THIS BEHIND US NOW
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN UPLOADED
THIS YEAR'S PRETTY SUCCESSFULLY
AGAINST REPOSSESSION INDUSTRY
AND ALSO. THE CHOICE IS ALWAYS
A DA REJECT THAT PARTICULAR
MOMENT REPOSSESSIONS PUT IN
JAIL THE TRUCK IS ENCOUNTERED
AND THE PERSON GETS THE CLUB.
AND WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FUTURE SOME PEOPLE DON'T-
RACKED UP ARREST RECORDS WHEN
THEY'RE ON. THEY'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING WRONG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO.
I ALWAYS FORGET NOW DO A NEED
TO GET MY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT OKAY SO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THIS HEARING. SEEING
NONE I WILL LOOK INTO THE
REMOTE ROOM SEEING NINE
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP ANY
WITNESSES WHO HAVE CALLED IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OR
SORRY AB. FIVE FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT. THEN WE WILL
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WHO ARE- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED SO I KNOW THAT I
DON'T HAVE ANY KEY WITNESSES
AND IDENTIFIED ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NINE.
AND THERE ARE NONE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM SO MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE ONE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT-
LET'S SEE IF ANY OF OUR- MEMBER
SEVENTY COMMENTS OR- THE NEW
YORKER COBBLER. THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR- SO I ACTUALLY WAS-
THE CONFUSED AND THE HEARING
THE TESTIMONY WAS HELPFUL-
CURRENTLY IF YOU ARE RE
PROCESSING PROPERTY YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO GO- ONTO SOMEONE'S
PRIVATE PROPERTY TO GET. THE
ITEM YES THEY CANNOT GO TO ANY
LOCKED FACILITY- THEY CANNOT
UNLOCK A CAR- THEY CANNOT GO TO
ANY PRIVATE PROPERTY IN AT OUT
HOUSE OUTSIDE EIGHTY YOU NOR
CAN THEY GO TO THE PRIVATE
PROPERTY. OF FOR EXAMPLE HOME.
RIGHT THIS BILL WOULD BE
PARTICULAR TO A PUBLIC PARKING
LOT PERCENT OKAY OR IF IT'S
SOMETHING IS IN SOMEONE'S
DRIVEWAY. THAT'S CORRECT OR AS
WAS IN THE ANALYSIS THE SOLAR
PANELS. IF ON SOMEONE'S ROOF.
IN REGARDS TO THAT I BELIEVE A
MISTER JOE CONNOR GVA RESEARCH
AND GET SOME CLARIFICATION
QUESTION THE SOLAR PANELS OKAY
SO CURRENTLY SOMEONE WOULD
REPOSSESS A CAR FOR EXAMPLE
THAT'S IN THE- PARKING LOT AT
THE AT THE SUPERMARKET AND THEN
SOMEONE. WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
PEOPLE ARE CALLING THE POLICE.
ON THAT PERSON BECAUSE THE RE
PROCESSING THAT VEHICLE. AND SO
THIS IS TO CORRECT VATS YES
SENATOR OKAY ARE YOU THREE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE OUR-
REPOSSESSED RIPPING FALSELY
APPREHENDED AND LATER ON THEIR
CASES DISMISSED TO REALIZE THAT
THEY ARE AT 3% FOR THEIR LEGAL
HAVE THE RIGHT TO REPRESENTS
THAT A CARD. PROPERTY PROJECT
OKAY OKAY SO FOR ME THAT WAS
THE I THOUGHT OH THIS MEANS YOU
CAN COME ONTO SOMEONE'S
PROPERTY WHEN IT'S- YOU KNOW NO
TRESPASSING. TO GO BUT YOU'RE
SAYING IT'S ONLY FOR PUBLIC
EXPOSED- LOCATIONS YES CENTER
AND I APPRECIATE THOSE
QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- SENATOR WIENER YOU HAVE
A QUESTION YEAH AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT SO WE ALREADY
HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS TO GOING TO
BE ABLE TO REPOSSESS AND TO
ENTER AND LEAVE. IMMEDIATELY
BUT THEY'RE GETTING- THEY'RE
THEY'RE GETTING ARRESTED AND
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LEGAL
PROCESS. AND POTENTIALLY HAVE
TO HAVE A RECORD EXPUNGED
AFTERWARDS THE REST ARE RECORD-
AND THIS WHICH IS MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN ESSENTIALLY. DO
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY AUTHORIZED
TO DO WITHOUT HAVING TO BE
ARRESTED AND PROSECUTED
GROSSMAN EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS
THAT IS EXACTLY CORRECT OKAY-
I'M BEYOND HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. SENATOR OF CHILDREN TO
HAVE COMMON OR QUESTIONS OKAY.
RIGHT SIR- BEFORE WE- CAKE
BROKAW WILL ALLOW YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN ACOSTA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
MEASURE EXCELLENT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION IT IS TO DO PASSED BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMEDIAN
OF PROBES. BROKAW AB FIVE
FIFTEEN BRADFORD A CHOI BOGUE.
CHARBAGH GUY CAMARGO I FELT
LIKE- I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE IF FOUR
ZERO. SO AB FIVE FIFTEEN IS OUT
FOUR TWO ZERO THANK YOU I THINK
RUN FROM 10% IN. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OUR- FOR KILL. WHERE
WE ARE NOW HEARING ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I THINK THE CHAIRED
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK TODAY CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
JUDGES TO IMPOSE A SENTENCE FOR
THE OFFENSE OF CARRYING THE
LONGEST POSSIBLE TERM OF
IMPRISONMENT IS FUNDED IS
ACCUSED OF MULTIPLE OFFENSES
DURING A SINGLE ACT THIS TOUGH
ON CRIME- POLICY REMOVES THE
DISCRETION THAT JUDGES
PREVIOUSLY HAD TO CHARGE A
DEFENDANT WITH THE SENTENCE
DEEMED MOST APPROPRIATE
DEPENDING ON THE CONTEXT CON.
CONTEXT OF THE CRIME. CONTINUE
TO PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR THE
LONGEST AMOUNT OF TIME
REGARDLESS OF THE CONTEXT OF
THE CRIME. AND HISTORY OF THE
OFFENDER DOES NOT REHABILITATE
THE PERSON OR GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO BE BETTER IN THE
FUTURE. OVER THE LAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN STEPS TO
REVERSE THE HARSH POLICIES OF
THE PAST BY RESTORING JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. AND INDIVIDUALIZED
SENTENCING. SB FIVE EIGHTEEN
RESOURCES DISCRETION THE JUDGES
PREVIOUSLY HAD. GIVING THEM THE
ABILITY TO FAIRLY SENTENCE AND
ACT AND TO EXERCISE DISCRETION
WHEN DETERMINING A SENTENCE FOR
AN ACT PUNISHABLE IN DIFFERENT
WAYS. BY DIFFERENT VERY
PROVISIONS OF LAW. WE MUST
CONTINUE. FORWARD AND WORK
TOWARDS MODERNIZING OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM BY ENSURING THAT
SENTENCES ARE APPROPRIATE TO
THE ACT. BY PHONE TODAY I'VE
STEVEN MUNN CELTICS ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
TO TESTIFY. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IBM. FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM YOUR- MAIN WITNESS IN
SUPPORT MR MONK HELPED. ARMY
MAY BE PERCEIVED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN- I AM VERY
EXECUTIVE RECORDS CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WHICH IS A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL- EXPERTS FROM MANY FIELDS
HAVE SHOWN US THAT THIS THE
MASS INCARCERATION POLICY IN
THE LAST FORTY YEARS IS BAD
POLICY. IT'S FAR MORE EXPENSIVE
ARE LESS FAVORABLE OUTCOMES FOR
SOCIETIES AND SHORTER SENTENCES
ALL OF OUR SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME TO
HELP THEM ESTABLISH IMPLEMENT.
A LOT OF OUR LIFESTYLES. BUT
NINETY SO AND THEN THE TO KILL
BECAUSE SECTION SIX FOUR WEST
OF THEM INCARCERATION MOVEMENT.
IT TOOK DISCRETION AWAY FROM
THE JUDGE WHOSE CONSTITUTIONAL
ROLE IS TO DECIDE ON AN
APPROACH APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT
FOR CRIMES AND GIVE IT TO
PROSECUTORS PROPER ROLE IS TO
SEE A CONVICTION AN ADVOCATE
FOR PUNISHMENT. THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING AT THIS POINT THAT
THIS WAS A MISTAKE CHANGES LIKE
THIS UNBALANCED OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM MAKING IT LESS
JUST AND MORE EXPENSIVE. AB
FIVE CAN SIMPLY REVERSES THE
CHANGE MADE IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. IT GIVES DISCRETION BACK
TO THE JUDGE TO WEIGH THE CRIME
THE DEFENDANT AND THE
SURROUNDING CIRCUMSTANCES TO
FIND A JUST SENTENCE IN THE
PARTICULAR CASE. THE ARGUMENTS
OPPOSING THE BILL FROM C. AIR
SHOW QUITE CLEARLY THAT THEY
HAVE NOT LEARNED ANYTHING FROM
DECADES OF HARM DONE BY MASS
INCARCERATION. THEY'RE STILL
ARGUING THAT THE ONLY SENSE
WHICH CAN EVER BE JUSTIFIED AS
THE MOST JUDITH WHAT. EVERY
CRIME AND EVERY DESCENDANT IS
DIFFERENT. WE NEED JUDGES WHO
STAND APART FROM THE
ADVERSARIAL CONTEST TO FIND
JUSTICE IN EACH CASE BY
IMPOSING AN APPROPRIATE
SENTENCE WHICH IS NOT ALWAYS
THE MOST PUNITIVE. THIS IS A
SENSIBLE AMENDMENT WE ASK FOR
YOUR SOCIAL. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD WITNESSES
THAT SINGLE OR SINGLE LEAD
WITNESS. APART SAID HER SINGLE
LEAD WITNESS BUT LET US SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE WILL LOOK IN
YOUR FLOW ROOM SEEING NINE.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- QUEUE
UP ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN Q.
OR GOING TO WIND SEVENTEENTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARE NOT ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I'M FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MERGING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAROLINA
APPROVED ON THE HAS IT OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- WE DO HAVE A LEAD OF
OPPOSING WITNESS AND THAT IS
MISTER MORRIS FROM TH
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION YOU MAY PERCEIVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN. THE PURPOSE
BEHIND THE CURRENT VERSION OF
PENAL CODE SECTION SIX FIFTY
FOUR IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUNISHMENT FITS THE CRIME AND
THE DEFENDANT RECEIVES NEITHER
EXCESSIVE PUNISHMENT NOR
EXCESSIVE LENIENCY. THE
LANGUAGE THAT AB FIVE EIGHTEEN
NOW SEEKSTO EXCLUDE WAS ADDED
TO SECTION SIX REPORT IN
LEGISLATION OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO TO PREVENT A DEFENDANT FROM
RECEIVING WHAT AMOUNTED TO A
SENTENCING WINDFALL. AS THE
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY OF THAT
AMENDMENT MADE CLEAR THE
LEGISLATURE WAS PROPERLY
CONCERNED OTHER DEFENDANTS WHO
COMMITTED A MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSE. FALL COMMITTING
SIMULTANEOUSLY AT SECOND LEFT
DURING THE GROUND ARISING FROM
THE SAME COURSE OF CONDUCT
COULD THE STATE APPROPRIATE
PUNISHMENT ON THE MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSE. WHEREAS THE DEFENDANT
WILL ONLY A MINUTE THE MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSE BUT NOT. THAT
STOOD. LOGIC INPUT. LOOK AT.
FOR EXAMPLE BEFORE PC FIFTY
FOUR WAS A MAN. I DEFENDED
COULD CONVICTED OF KID THE OF
ABROAD. AND ALSO CONVICT OF THE
CRIME ACROSS. COULD BE
SENTENCED ONLY FOR THE ROBERT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE NOTED THEM
QUOTE IT DEFIES COMMON SENSE
THAT A DEFENDANT CONVICTED OF A
STRING OF CRIMES COULD AVOID
BEING SENTENCED ON THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIME FOR WHICH YEAR
SHE WAS CONVICTED AND QUOTE.
THAT REASONING IS EQUALLY APT
TODAY. LET ME PROVIDE A FEW
EXAMPLES OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FALL INTO COULD COME
FROM PASSAGE OF THIS BILL.
PERSON COULD BE TRY WITH THE
BLOWS MURDERED FOR THIS CAR.
UNDER THIS THE JUDGE TO
SENTENCE THE FIRST SO. FOR THE
FALL. AND SAY THE MURDER. OR
CONSIDERING IN WHICH SOMEONE
CHARGED MURDER DRIVING DRUNK.
AND THEY'RE ALSO TRYING THE
TICKET FOR THE- UNDER BILL
JUDGE. JUST ON TO YOU I DIDN'T
STAY THE FEDERAL MARKET. THERE
ARE SOME OF KARJAT ALL. UNDER
THIS BILL IS COULD SENTENCE ON
THE AUTO ALONG AND- THEN ON THE
MORE. HARD JACK. BY CETERA
PERSON THE BACK OF A BIO WAY
AND THIS BY BUT SAME. AGAIN
UNDER EIGHT FIVE EIGHTEEN THE
JUDGE IT'S ON THE SEX BATTERY
ONLY. AND STATE OR THAT. THE
GIRL LAW THAT THE BILL SEEKS TO
AMEND THE GROUP DRAFTED THIS.
TO AVOID THESE KINDS OF NON.
OUT WE ARE OF ANY IN. ARE SO.
IT'S THEM PROBLEMS STEMMING
FROM THE ONE. THE CHANGES
SIMPLY UNLESS. WE ALL YOU WILL
TAKE CONSIDER THE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND CERTAIN- LITIGATE
BECAUSE I BY WILL. OF THE
COMMON LIMITATION CURRENTLY
EXISTING IN SECTION. SIX FIFTY
FOUR. ACTUALLY ABSOLUTE NOBLE.
PART ON WHETHER LEAD OPPOSITE
PERSON RICK- DESIGNATED SO AND
WE WILL GO TO- OPPOSITION WHO
FIRST SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM. HERE PRESENTS NO- IN
IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S
NOT SO MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY. COLORS THAT ARE
WANT TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT SO- I HAVE A QUESTION.
ON THE IN THE OPPOSITION'S-
STATEMENT I'M NOT SURE IF IT
WAS SAID BY MISTER MORRIS BUT
I'M JUST READING- ACTUALLY IT
WAS ONLY SOMETHING THAT THE D.
ASUS- SUBMITTED WHICH SAYS THAT.
IT DEFIES COMMON SENSE THAT A
DEFENDANT CONVICTED OF A STRING
OF CRIMES COULD AVOID BEING
SENTENCED ON THE MOST SERIOUS
CRIME FOR WHICH HE OR SHE IS
CONVICTED AND MY QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR IS. YOUR BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT TO JUDGE FROM.
SENTENCING UNDER THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIME DOES IT RACKED
THEY CAN STILL- SENTENCE THE
MOST SEVERE PUNISHMENT FOR THE
MOST SERIOUS PART OF THE CORE
OF THE CRIME SHOULD THEY SO
CHOOSE. OKAY SO IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY. BUT IT WELL THE MY
REAL POINT IS THAT IF. WHILE
THE JUDGE MADE A SORT
DISCRETION. THERE STILL COULD
BE OBVIOUSLY BUT D. M. THE MOST
SERIOUS OFFENSE COULD BE THAT
WHICH IS- SENSE UNDER IN ANY
AND ANY ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS
OR WHAT HAVE YOU THAT MAY BE ON
THE BOOKS THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY
JUST GIVE THE JUDGE MORE
OPTIONS DEPENDING ON THE
CONTEXT OF THE CRIME AND THE
PERPETRATOR OF THE CRIME AND
WHATEVER OTHER. EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY WANT TO TAKE
INTO. ACCOUNT WHEN THEIR-
GIVING UP SENTENCING. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- LET ME SEE IF ANY
FURTHER MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS MONTH. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION- I. WANT
TO SAY SENATOR I MEAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS- THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE BILL BECAUSE-
WHO. JUDICIAL DISCRETION I
THINK THERE WAS A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE IT WILL THERE WAS A
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE THE STATE.
PERHAPS GAVE TOO MUCH DISTANCE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION BUT THEN WE
KIND OF. LIKE IN THE PENDULUM
WE WENT FROM PERHAPS TOO MUCH
TO THEN. PRETTY MUCH
RESTRICTING NONE I THINK NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THAT
BALANCE. AND WHILE JUDGES ARE
LIKE MANY OTHER PEOPLE THEY'RE
NOT PERFECT. CERTAINLY THEY
ARE. THEY ARE IN EITHER ELECTED
OR APPOINTED TO THE BENCH WITH
THE- WITH PEOPLE'S INTENTION OR
THE POINTERS INTENTION THAT
THEY- ARE COMPETENT THAT THE
UNDERSTAND THE LAW. AND THAT IN
THOSE CASES WERE DAY. HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXERCISE DISCRETION
THAT THEY WILL USE GOOD I
ALWAYS LOVE THIS WORD JUDGMENT
IN DOING SO AND SO I THINK THAT
THERE IS A REAL VALUE BECAUSE
IN THE SAME WAY THAT WHEN THE
PURPOSE OF TO MY POINT OF VIEW
A JURY TRIAL. IS THAT WE ARE
BRINGING IN A JURY OF THEIR
PEERS TO HAVE PEOPLE SSS
CIRCUMSTANCE AND USE THEIR OWN
JUDGMENT HOWEVER IN EVEN WITH
THE- WITH OUR JURY SYSTEM NOW
THEY DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND.
THAT THE JUDGE MAY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO SENSE THE CERTAIN
WAY AND THEN IN EFFECT WERE
ALMOST UNDERMINING THE WHOLE-
JURY PROCESS SO. I THINK THAT
THE BALANCE OF RESTORING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IS A WISE
THING AT THIS POINT TO DO. I'M
SORRY PRESHEAF YOUR BILL AND GO
AHEAD SENATOR CORMANN ORDER.
SORRY I GOT CAUGHT UP I JUST
WANNA- ECHO YOUR SENTIMENTS
MADAM CHAIR- AND YOU KNOW THE
REALITY IS THAT WE HAVE A LOVE
HATE RELATIONSHIP WITH JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WE WANT JUDGES TO
HAVE IT UNTIL WE DON'T LIKE
WHAT THEY DO AND THEN WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO HAVE IT. AND SO I
THINK WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO GET OVER THAT SCHIZOPHRENIA-
AND ALLOW WE HAVE TO PUT OUR
FAITH TO WHAT GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN TOLD US ON THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE. OUR REVISION
COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO PUT OUR
FAITH IN THE JUDGES. AND HAVE
FAITH THAT THEY CAN DO THEIR
JOB. AND IF THEY CAN'T. THEN
YOU COME BACK AND SAY HOW CAN
WE HELP PROVIDE THEM GREATER
GUIDANCE. THEY ACTUALLY ON. THE
SIDE OF CONSERVATIVE SENTENCING
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE
KNEE JERK REACTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AND ALSO THE
PUBLIC. AND THE OTHER REALITY
IS THAT WHEN WE'RE COMING UP
WITH THESE LAWS AROUND
SENTENCING SAID THE YEARS ARE
REALLY ARBITRARY. THEY ARE
ARBITRARY AND THEN WE BUILD ON
THEM WITH ENHANCEMENTS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. AND THE FOUND
AND YET THE FOUNDATION. THERE'S
NO ANALYSIS BEHIND THE
ORIGINAL- BASED SENTENCE TIME
AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO JUST
RECKON WITH THAT THAT'S HOW WE
HAVE HAD THIS EXPLOSIVE
METASTASIZE PRISON POPULATION
BECAUSE WE'RE PICKING NUMBERS
THAT SOUND RIGHT AND THERE'S NO
ONE ALICE'S BEHIND THEM. AND
THEN WE HAMSTRING JUDGES
ABILITY- TO USE THEIR BRAIN
WHICH IS WHY GENERALLY WHY
THEY'VE BEEN APPOINTED OR WE
VOTED FOR THEM BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT WHAT'S IN THEIR
BRAIN IS OKAY. AND IT MAKES
COMPLETE SENSE TO OFFER RANGES
AND TO ALLOW JUDGES TO USE
DISCRETION TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS APPROPRIATE BASED ON THE
CHARGE AND BASED ON THE CRIME
IN BASED ON THE EVIDENCE AND
INSTEAD WE HAVE PROSECUTORS.
WHO WANT TO JUST READ. SERCOMBE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES THE
NUANCES AND COMPLEXITIES TO A
CASE TO THESE ARBITRARILY
DECIDED. SENTENCING YEARS AND
THEN HOLD EVERYONE ACCOUNTABLE
TO THAT AND THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE UNIVERSE THAT IS COMPLETELY
BLACK AND WHITE EXCEPT THAT
SOMEBODY WILL BE BORN AND
SOMEBODY WILL DIE. THOSE ARE
THE ONLY THINGS THAT ARE
CONSTANT. SOURCE FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS THAT I DO SUPPORT THIS
AND I WANTED TO SHARE BUT I GOT
CAUGHT UP IN READING SOMETHING
ELSE AND SO THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME AND SO GOOD TO SEE
YOU. TO RIGHT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FOR YOU TO GO AHEAD
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU- SAN
SKINNER ON THAT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD ITHINK YOU
KNOW REGARDLESS OF. WHETHER
IT'S JUDICIAL DISCRETION OR NOT
OR SINCE THE WAY THAT THE PENAL
CODE IS RED AND OR ONE HAND
SPENCER ARE WHAT THE BAY SENSES
ARE. THE COMMONALITY AROUND ALL
OF THIS IS THAT WE DESIGNED- A-
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS DESIGNS. TO IMPOSE THE
MAXIMUM POSSIBLE PENALTY
WHETHER IT'S- MANDATING THE
JUDGES- IMPOSE THE HIGHEST
SENTENCE OR PROHIBITING JUDGES.
FROM POSE INFORMATION OF THE
BILL- THAT WE HAD AND- SOMEWHAT
CLOSER TO THIS MORNING OR- THE
PILING ON OF ENDLESS
ENHANCEMENTS. IT'S JUST IT'S A
SYSTEM THAT'S MOVED AWAY FROM
HOW DO WE PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
HOW DO WE REHABILITATE PEOPLE
TO HIRE WHICH IS PACKED PEOPLE-
IN THE PRISON. AND YOU KNOW
IT'S A IT'S A- IT'S A FAILURE
IT HASN'T WORKED- IT'S JUST
TAKEN YOU KNOW WITH THIS
ENDLESS SUCKING. SOUND OF MONEY
INTO THE PRISON SYSTEM. AND YOU
KNOW THE INTEREST IS A YOU YOU
LOOK AT OUR PRESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA. EVEN WITH ALL THE
REDUCTIONS THAT HAPPENS DURING
COVE IT IT'S STILL REALLY HIGH.
IT SALLY WE HAVE LIKE A
SPARSELY POPULATED STATE PRISON
SYSTEM ITSELF HIGH IT'S NOT.
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY HI THE WAY
IT WAS WERE WAS SO CROWDED THAT
YOU COULDN'T EVEN HAVE LIKE
ENOUGH BED SPACE LET ALONE
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE. BUT IT'S
STILL REALLY HIGH EVEN AFTER
THE RATHER DRAMATIC REDUCTION
DURING COVE IT AND BECAUSE OF
REALIGNMENT ETCETERA. AND SIGN
THAT SHOWS JUST HOW- POORLY
DESIGNED THE SYSTEM IS AND HOW
SERVE HONESTLY IMMORAL- IT IS
AND SO I'M I'M SORRY THAT THE
DA'S FELT THE NEED TO OPPOSE-
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL I HOPE WE
CAN MOVE AWAY FROM. ON SOME OF
THE KNEE JERK OPPOSITION TO
ANYTHING THAT MEANS LESS
INCARCERATION- THIS IS A GOOD
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SOME RIVER WORKS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YOU
GUYS DID A GOOD JOB CLOSING FOR
ME WHICH IS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. RIGHT SEE NO
OTHER COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION- WHICH SENATOR WIENER
MADE FIRED CORRECT YES- SO THE-
MOTION IS. TO PASS FOR FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PROBES. AND APPROPRIATIONS-
POWER COUNCIL MISS KENNEDY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN BRADFORD A CHOI BOGUE.
CHARBONEAU COM LONGER I AM
LARGER AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER
I WINNER WINNER I'D VOTERS
THREE TO ONE RIGHT THANK YOU
YOUR BILL IS OUT THREE TWO ONE
AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO THE
MOMENT AFTER THE CLEANING ALLOW
FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALL. I
THANK YOU
- YES PATTERSON OF.
THEREFORE I'M CONFIRM OKAY I'LL
TELL THE COMMITTEE AGAIN IN
ORDER FOR BILLS ON CONSENT AND-
THOSE BILLS WERE AB TWO SIXTY
THREE AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND THEN-
AB TWO FIVE THREE MISTER
PATTERSON WILL BE HEARD NEXT
WEEK AND WE ARE NOW GOING TO
HEAR. FORTY OKAY BUT WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO HEAR FROM YOU
CAN USE ME- AB. THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR EVEN THOUGH MY NOTE STATE
CHAIR BRADFORD PUT. YOU'RE
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE. YOU
CHAIRMANSHIP DINNER- TODAY I'M
REPRESENT AND PRESENTING AB
THIRTY THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN TO
PREVENT PREDATORY PRACTICES IN
THE BAIL AND IMMIGRATION BOND
INDUSTRIES BY ELIMINATING BAIL
RENEWAL PREMIUMS. THIS BILL
ALSO PROVIDES RECOURSE FOR
THOSE FORCED TO PAY RENEWAL
FEES BY ALLOWING THEM TO
COLLECT DAMAGES FOR ANY
VIOLATION BEFORE I PROCEED WITH
MY COMMENTS. LIKE TO SHARE MY
OFFICE HAS HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
LAST MINUTE OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL. END THANKS TO MY STAFF
OUR SPONSORS AND ESPECIALLY THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. I
AGREE TO MAKE THE FOLLOWING IN
MEN'S AND THE NEXT COMMITTEE
WHICH WILL ONE REMOVED A
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION TO
EXISTING POLICIES RELATING TO
IMMIGRATION BONDS. AND TO
INCLUDE BUT DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
IMMIGRATION BOND SECTION TO
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THE
OPPOSITION HAS AGREED TO GO
NEUTRAL. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PROTECT FINANCIALLY
BURDENED DEPENDENCE AND THE
FAMILIES AGAINST UNJUSTIFIED
FEES BY PROHIBITING BAIL AND
MIGRATION BOND AGENTS TO CHARGE
A POOL SECOND PREMIUM TO A
PERSON WHO HAS NOT HAD THEIR
CASE RESOLVED WITHIN TWELVE
MONTHS ONE YEAR THE AVERAGE
BELT IN CALIFORNIA IS FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. MOST OF US
MOST PEOPLE MOST OF US DO NOT
HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AVAILABLE SO MANY FAMILIES ARE
FORCED TO TURN TO A BAIL AGENT
THAT WILL CHARGE THEM 10% OF
THE TOTAL AMOUNT BUT- AS A
PREMIUM. THAT MEANS FAMILIES
ARE LOCKED INTO PAYING FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
THEIR LOVED ONES CASES IS NOT
RESOLVED. THE BILL COMPANY THEY
ARE UNDER CONTRACT WITH CHARGES
OF RENEWAL PREMIUM. TO COVERT
NINETEEN COURTS ARE
EXPERIENCING SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG LEADING TO LONGER TALK
TIME LINES IN CASES TO BE
HEARD. A RECENT REPORT FOUND
THAT AT LEAST ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED UNATTENDED. AND
SENTENCED PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LOCKED IN COUNTY JAILS FOR
LONGER THAN THREE YEARS.
AWAITING A TRIAL OR SENTENCING.
AND IN IMMIGRATION COURT
BACKLOGS SHOWS THAT THERE OVER
A HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
THOUSAND PENDING CASES WITH AN
AVERAGE TIMELINE OF TWO TO
THREE YEARS. THEY'VE REMAINED
UNRESOLVED FOR THESE REASONS
I'VE AMENDED THE BILL IN HIS
COMMITTEE TO BUY PROTECTIONS TO
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES. SIMPLY PUT
FAMILY SHOULD NOT BE FORCED TO
TAKE AN UNFAIR I'M FARE COSTS
JUST TO HAVE THEIR LOVED ONE
SAFE AT HOME WHETHER WAITING
FOR THE TRIAL OR SENTENCING.
WITH ME TO RESPECT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS MICHAEL
MARTINEZ. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL. AND RIOS SCARF WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS. OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. MEMBERS EXPECTED ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU- CHEER
JONES SAWYER WE'LL START WITH
MISTER MARTINEZ GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AS A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING
THIS MEASURE. I ALSO CONCUR
WITH THE AUTHOR REGARDING
AMENDMENTS HE JUST PROBABLY
DESCRIBED IN ACCEPTED IN HIS
TESTIMONY. WE ARE PURSUING AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THIS YEAR
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT ON
BAIL BONDS AND IMMIGRATION
BONDS ARE BEING SUBJECT TO
UNNECESSARY. NONREFUNDABLE
RENEWAL FEES. ALLEN HAS BEEN
COMPOUNDED EVEN MORE DURING
THIS PANDEMIC WHICH IS CAUSED
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN COURT
CASES BEING HEARD. CHARGING THE
SAME NONREFUNDABLE FEE MOLD
CLAIMS WHEN IT CONSUMERS CASES
NOT BEEN RESOLVED WITHIN TWELVE
MONTHS IS AN ARBITRARY
PRACTICES USED BY THE BILL
INSURANCE INDUSTRY TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL PROFITS. OFF
UNSUSPECTING CONSUMERS THIS
PRACTICE IS ABSOLUTELY UNFAIR
TO CONSUMERS THIS BILL IS
NEEDED NOW TO HELP CURB THESE
PREDATORY BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THAT MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO CHARGE
THESE UNNECESSARY NON
REFUNDABLE RENEWAL FEES. ON
BILL BONDS AND IMMIGRATION
BONDS. AND IN ADDITION THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE HARM
CONSUMERS WITH THE CRUCIAL
ABILITY TO COLLECT DAMAGES FOR
ANY VIOLATION WHICH COULD
OTHERWISE THREATEN THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF HARD
WORKING FAMILIES WHO ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVERS ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW GO TO MR
SCHARF. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RIO SHARK FROM AN ATTORNEY AT
THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA I MANAGE THE BILL CONNECT
LEGAL SERVICES CLINIC FOR
CONSUMERS A BAIL BONDS
IMMIGRATION BONDS WE REPRESENT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED CLIENTS
ELIMINATED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THAT. OUR
CLIENT EXPERIENCE A WIDE RANGE
OF ABUSES THE PRESSURE IN THE
FINAL CONTRACT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND MISLED ABOUT THE
TERMS AND THE CASE AGGRESSIVE
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICE IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE THEY ARE HIGHLY
VULNERABLE TO MISTREATMENT.
PEOPLE PICKING BAYLOR
IMMIGRATION BONTA DESPERATE
KIND OF SECURE THEIR OWN
RELEASE OR THEIR LOVED ONES
RELEASE FROM JAIL OR DETENTION
FACILITY EACH ADDITIONAL THEIR
THE PENSION INCREASES THE RISK
AND COUNTERING VIOLENT
CONTRACTING A VIRUS LOSING HIS
JOB OR EVEN CUT THE APPOINT
KIDS. PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE AND
COMPANY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
BECAUSE WE CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT
IN A POSITION TO NEGOTIATE FAIR
AND REASONABLE CONTRACT TERMS
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT PROTECT THEM AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN DOES JUST
BACK. IT COMPANIES FROM ACROSS
OR COLLECTING ANNUAL RENEWAL.
EITHER OF TERMS THAT WE-
CONSUMER WILL GROW. TO AGREE TO
IT I'M- THAT. FOR HELPING OUT
THERE ARE. ONLY PURPOSE THESE
FEES OF TWENTY EIGHT BOND
COMPANY. BUT THEIR IMPACT
IMPACT THE BOTTOM PEOPLE HAVE
LONG QUICKER. THE COSBY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BY
LENGTHENING COURT PROCEEDINGS
HAVE SUBJECTED MANY MORE PEOPLE
TO THE ANNUAL RENEWAL PREMIUM.
SO NOW REALLY IS A CRITICAL
TIME TO ADDRESS THIS PRACTICE.
IN ADDITION TO BE HARMFUL THESE
EITHER UNNECESSARY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF SUCCESSFUL COMPANIES
OPERATING WITHOUT THEM. IT JUST
ACTUALLY LAUDABLE THE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN INCLUDE
IMMIGRATION BONDS ANNUAL
RENEWAL PREMIUMS ARE VERY
COMMON IN THE CONTRACT AND
THESE CONSUMERS ARE ESPECIALLY
UNLIKELY TO SPEAK UP ABOUT
CONTRACT TERMS. EDUCATED PENDLE
AFTER THAN CASE MEANING CONSUME.
HAVE TO PAY MORE ANNUAL RENEWAL
FEES OVER TIME. WE MUST NOT LET
THE IMMIGRATION BOND INDUSTRY
BECOME OUT AND TRANSIENT. THE
BILL WANT INDUSTRY HAVE BECOME
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO GET AHEAD
OF ABUSIVE PRACTICES IN THE
INDUSTRY AND WE SHOULD SEIZE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO INCLUDE AN
ANNUAL RENEWAL PREMIUMS AREN'T
ANY OF PRACTICE EXTRACT WEALTH
FROM PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS TOO WONDERFUL TO
NEGOTIATE PREPARE TERMS. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN IS A MUCH
NEEDED AND LONG OVERDUE LAW
THAT WILL BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS
IN DIRE NEED. OF PROTECTION.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU- SO NOW
WE'LL SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THAT ARE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NONE. TEN KNOWN IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM MODERATOR YOU CAN
QUEUE UP. ANY CALLERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN
Q. REPORTER MIND THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEWMAN CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS POLICY OF
YOUR QUESTION AND ALLOW POVERTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MISSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARCH YOU KNOW WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND TRONG REPORT. THANK
YOU I TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANNECKER ADHARMA ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT I'M
SURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF FUNDING AS ON BEHALF THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAROLINA BID ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU CARE ACT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES LARRY MORE
SUNDAY AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION THERE IS ONE
LISTED WE'LL SEE IF THEY ARE
STILL WANTED TO TESTIFY AND
THAT IS MISTER SECTION AND FROM
THE AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION.
MORTGAGOR MEMBERS MY NAME MARC
SEGMENT WHICH AMERICAN PROPERTY
CATHOLIC CHURCH LOCATION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND IT STOPPED WORKING WITH THE
AMENDED. SURE THE BILL DOES NOT
IMPOSE RETROACTIVE REQUIREMENT
BUT A BIT INVOLVED IN A LOT OF
COMPANIES TIME BOB CORKER
GREAT. BUT MANAGE API. ABLE GO
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. OKAY I'M-
I THINK THE OTHER PERSON IS NOT
GOING TO TESTIFY MY INFORMATION
IS CORRECT WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER LEAD OPPOSITION SO
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY-
PERSONS IN HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WANT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. C. NINE ANYONE IN
THE OTHER ROOM SHE NINE SO NOW
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES. MMHM ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BUT BEFORE WE ACT
WE WILL ALLOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRANSFERRED TO PLEASE CLOSE
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. RIGHT RIGHT THE MOTION ON
THIS ONE IS. THE PASSWORD FIRST
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. ALL RIGHT MS KENNEDY
ROLL CALL BRADFORD A TROPE A
TROPE BOTH TROUBLE GUY CALM
WATER HI I'M LONGER AYE SKINNER
ART IN OUR AYE WIENER. WIENER
AYE FORTY ZERO RIGHT THE BILLS
OUT FOUR TO ZERO THANKS A LOT
THANK YOU. THE OKAY NOW WE HAVE
ONE LAST BILL NO WE DON'T MR
LOS WAS ON CONSENT YOU'RE RIGHT
THIS IS IT MY GOODNESS WHAT A
FAST EFFICIENT COMMITTEE. ON
OKAY. WHAT. YES WHITE
IMPRESSIVE ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
STAFF AND THAT THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY IS. ASSURED.
THANK.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR
CONFERENCE IS ENDING NOW PLEASE
HANG UP.